during the past month our community has
seen three murder suicides
one in a summerlin apartment another in
the southwest valley
and one on the las vegas strip bianca
holman shares one southern nevada
resource looking to prevent
these types of situations from this
apartment complex in summerlin where a
married couple was found
to a teen finding his mother and father
shot and killed in the southwest valley
then a wind security officer shot and
killed by another wind employee
who then turned the gun on himself at
the resort's employee parking garage
murder suicides have been in our
headlines recently many people are
feeling the stress of the pandemic
unemployment financial issues depression
and isolation
but advocates from the family justice
center want to help those who are
feeling hopeless and overwhelmed
before the stress boils over and more
lives are lost
the family justice center which has been
open since march of 2018
is actually a best practice model
we provide services to victims of
domestic violence human trafficking
and sexual assault under one roof and
the key to that is it's an array of
services on average a person seeking
help would have to travel more than 26
miles throughout our valley to reach
things like physical emotional or
financial resources
so the family justice center is a
catch-all providing everything one may
need
they serve more than 2 000 victims each
month it's a safe place
but it's also an environment where they
get to make choices
when they come in we don't say well
here's a police officer
and here's an advocate and these are all
the things that you're going to do
we ask them what they want and then we
help them to
navigate that no matter if you're a man
woman and teen in the midst of a crisis
or a concerned friend looking for
guidance greene says their doors
are always open bianca holman 8 news now
to access the city's resources you can
dial 2-1-1 or visit the family justice
center in person
they're located near washington and
mohave road